chemical but my name is Kate Roberts and
vice president of circulation services
international most of the foundry
invades and five and alive child
survival program yeah what I would like
to be able to sort Lee remembered for
especially a leader is also having be
selectively created public-private
partnerships and what I mean by that is
taking the dot floor note of CSR
corporate social responsibility and
putting it into the dot-com I to eat the
piano well I think the solution to
providing health care to the bottom
element is to use I rabbit sector
strategies to build markets and to
deliver learn keys and healthcare and
behavior change communication put it to
those people and people really need it
the most living at the bottom water
pyramid that there's trillions of
dollars worth of buying power in those
communities more than I would like
companies really to vote on that as an
effective tool to build their revenues
and to create win-win strategies around
corporate social responsibility